Barnaby was making big Impressions you
know he was a great Athlete on the pitch
but really good Off Pitch too and I
think that that the kids of his
generation will be really hard hit they
won't understand this as indeed nor do
we as adults but you know he'll leave a
big hole you know he's big personality
they're really inspirational young man
who had a bright future
he was one of those boys with a great
big smile very motivated very passionate
about All Sport but particularly
talented at Cricket and you know what
he's one of the guys in the team where
all his teammates would look to Barney
from age 9 10 onwards he was like he was
like almost their leader at such a young
age I think as he grew up we saw lots of
those sorts of things he produced good
performances at Cricket Club level I
believe he's just picked a play for
Nottingham University which was really
proud about and you know what just
having gone to UNI for the first year he
had a bright future in sport and
whatever he chose to do